das ist ja biotie kurs nageldesign
ausbildung grundkurs in köln 675 euro
zur anmeldung erhält was geht ab märz
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja da
hätte ich habe mir natürlich euch geht's
gut heute mal mit cap einfach weil meine
haare so übertrieben lang sind und ich
dringend zum friseur muss heute mit
einem thema auf das ich sehr gespannt
bin und mich sehr freue
einfach weil ich jemand bin ich hab auf
youtube kein add blockerin ich finde es
auch irgendwie dumm jetzt nichts gegen
die von euch die das benutzen ist
natürlich auch verständlich aber ich
finde ich kenne genug leute die
verdienen mit youtube jetzt nicht die
welt und das wird halt ganz klar auch
durch diese leute die networker benutzen
verstärkt jetzt wurde ich angerufen auf
jeden fall habe ich den blogger nicht
drin
und mir wird jeden tag eine menge
werbung angezeigt wenn ich auf youtube
unterwegs bin und ich bin auf die idee
gekommen
wir schauen uns heute zusammen mal
werbung an die ist ja oft war es echt
blöd und dumm manche werbung sind aber
auch ganz cool und ich habe mir gedacht
wir machen eine kleine challenger raus
und zwar kaufe ich alles was wir in der
werbung angezeigt wird ich habe letztens
schon so eine werbung gesehen da ging es
irgendwie um so sammer produkte von lidl
war das glaube ich und keine ahnung ich
stelle das wird sich vor so was habe ich
noch nie gesehen
ich weiß nicht ob ich das in dieses
video schon rein packe dass sich die am
test oder ob ich einzelne videos dazu
mache keine ahnung ich will gar nicht
angewandt wenn ihr die idee auch so
fertig dann lasst auf jeden fall jetzt
mal finden hat nach oben da und ich bin
gespannt wir fangen an
und ja ich mache erst mal meine
bildschirm aktivierung ich will einfach
nur sagen wir gehen zum anfang hier auf
meinen kanal weil dann bringt mir die
werfen johnstons was natürlich läuft und
nicht bei jedem video werbung aber wir
klicken uns einfach mal durch einen tag
lang fast wenn ihr das wieder noch nicht
gesehen habt schaut euch auf jeden fall
an
hier ist allerdings keine werbung
gekommen sehr schade wir machen weiter
so lange ich erkannt werden auch keine
werbung aber ich gebe euch die daumen
runter
was kommt nach oben als nächstes schauen
wir einfach mal das video von julian
baumann vielleicht hier werbung
passt nahtlos normalerweise vor jedem
video werbung aber war natürlich klar
dass wirklich aufnehmen und werbung
brauche keine kommt fehlt nur noch das
tier gleich wieder einen rasenmäher vor
der tür ein pferd so baby muss aber
eigentlich werbung kommen oder auch
nicht ach so ganz wichtig das sind
natürlich alles sachen die hier
angezeigt werden das ist natürlich auch
werbung aber eigentlich suche ich halt
werbung die als video kommt einfach weil
das unterhaltsamer ist also leute wir
haben hier eine aldi werbung und es geht
um sommerspaß jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
was aus so jetzt was auf wir machen
folgendes ich habe mir hier mal meine
notizen aufgeschlagen und ich schreibe
jetzt einfach alle sachen aus und
rechnet ist am ende dann zusammen und
ich bin mal gespannt was bei rumkommen
aber wir haben jetzt hier die all die
wasserrutsche für sieben euro 99 zeit
ich hoffe ihr habt das prinzip
verstanden und wir schauen einfach mal
weiter
dazu gehört der scheiße 100 euro aber
das ding ist so ein swimmingpool ist
natürlich gar nicht schlecht und ich
finde für soll für das teil 100 euro
wenn ich den einmal ausprobieren würde
bin ich gespannt ob der was taugt also
schreiben wir einfach mal dazu als wir
haben jetzt insgesamt schon 107 eur 990
ich habe das war es jetzt 90 kilo 599 ja
was soll ich damit dann egal ich
schreibe aber mal dazu bikini 599 und
jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich auch eine
badehose für mich und vieles mehr
ach so leute wir haben heute den
sechsten juni also mittwoch und morgen
donnerstag das gibt es erst ab morgen
aber das macht ja nix ich glaube es dann
ein so macht man einfach mal weiter mit
sam mendes you alles bei mcdonald's
bestellen da kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich
mcdonald's werbung
[Musik]
da habe ich jetzt überhaupt nicht
verstanden worum es geht wahrscheinlich
um irgendein vertrag könnte ich mir
jetzt kaufen ist aber übels langweilig
deswegen mache aber weiter mit dem
nächsten video vielleicht hier von taff
abhängiger trick 45.000 euro was ist das
für eine werbung also fast mal kurz
zusammen der will mir gerade verklickern
wenn ich nicht diesen check24 kanal
abonniere stirbt das letzte einhorn der
welt alles klar
schreibt mir mal bitte in die kommentare
wer diese werbung schon 58 sekunden
angeschaut hat gut da kann man nichts
kaufen
deswegen würde ich einfach sagen wir
schauen uns einfach mal mein mcdonald's
video an was ich mal gemacht habe eine
mcdonald's essen bin mal gespannt ob wir
werden ziemlich gut da kam keine wäre
und bin beim lieferservice bestellen
frank rost die schalten auch mal
[Musik]
ein auslandssemester in china eigentlich
möchte ich irgendwelche produkte kaufen
ich will nicht nach china sollte ich
jetzt einfach mal hier in die youtube
trends da kommt jetzt bestimmt aber auch
keine werbung kommt hier werbung man
ohne spaß das habe ich mir so leichter
vorgestellt
nirgendwo kommt vernünftige werbung
entweder ich soll nach china gehen
ich soll so ein dreck check24 kanal
abonnieren warum bin ich so weit unten
ich möchte doch einfach nur über die
neuesten produkte informiert werden okay
leute ich ende jetzt einfach das konzept
und zwar werde ich jetzt alle währungen
die mir angezeigt wird kaufen also es
ist jetzt egal ob so eine pre roll ist
oder einfach so eine einblendung wir
kaufen alles was mir auf 'youtube'
angezeigt wird weil sonst geht das video
zehn jahre bis ich mal werbung gefunden
hat wo man nicht nach china fliegen muss
so wir haben jetzt hier
dieses ding wird mir die ganzen
deutschland angezeigt schein bis zu 90
prozent rabatt ich gehe einfach mal kurz
zu shop ist irgendwie das gleiche wie
wish und ich würde sagen wir tragen
einfach mal das scheint ob es scheint
hat mit schleife jetzt blicken wir auf
das nächste video meinetwegen von
revisor leute hier die nächste werbung
aber fakt 21 eur 99 bettelte
jetzt bettelt kaufen bei uns bekommen
sie einen key für aktivierung des spiels
er war einfach mal ein bettelt so
langsam geht es voran irgendwas
brauchbares außer der pool ist finde ich
noch nicht dabei aber ich lasse mich
nicht unterkriegen irgendwas kommt schon
noch
ist schon wieder eine sprachreise seit
wann ich verstehe es überhaupt nicht
wir gehen mal wieder auf meinen kanal da
wurde mir so oft gute werbung angezeigt
so was haben wir hier
du kannst hier mehr zu hause leisten als
du denkst kredit werde jetzt auch noch
einen kredit aufnehmen was läuft auf
einem kanal für werbung was denkt ihr
denn bringt dem zuschauer sind daran
interessiert jetzt mal eben einen kredit
aufzunehmen aber noch baufinanzierung
meine zielgruppe liegt irgendwie
zwischen 26 meinetwegen da will doch
keiner ausbauen die haben wir noch mal
scheinen gehen wir einfach mal drauf
obwohl etwas anderes hier angezeigt
bekommen ich würde sagen wir nehmen
wieder das erste und zwar scheint hier
oben steht steigt die fähigkeit auf ich
bin ja ein junger was soll ich damit
kommt man das sieht eigentlich ganz gut
aus aber schnell weg ich finde die seite
scheiße so wenn jetzt keine werbung
kommt dann drehe ich aber durch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einen koffer okay das habe ich hier
haben wir das und brauchen einen koffer
von cristiano ronaldo 8 ist hier ein
schnäppchen 100 149 euro für einen
koffer es ist aber okay ich nehme ihn
natürlich in pink das ding ist es trifft
sich eigentlich sogar ganz gut weil ich
habe noch einen blauen koffer da hinten
aber da ist die rolle leicht schrott
deswegen ein neuer koffer wäre nicht
schlecht so xxl amazon
überraschungspaket hier ist mac im
kühlschrank
das ist viel zu wichtig hält wobei man
auch schon sagen dieses mac kühlschränke
die sind richtig gut die sind stylisch
die halten kühl also eigentlich sehen
sie nur besser aus als andere
kühlschrank wird
ich trage das einfach mal ganz
vorsichtig hier ein in meine notizen
muss ich aber ganz ehrlich sagen ich
hoffe ihr versteht das sowas gebe ich
nicht aus wir haben ja schon kühlschrank
deswegen brauchen wir keinen mehr vor
allem für 1.149 euro oder so kühlschrank
okay jetzt werden einem aber immerhin
hier produkte angezeigt und eurostar
okay das ist so krass was gibt es auf
youtube für werbung also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich finde es sehr
überraschend weil ich bin tagtäglich auf
youtube man nimmt diese werbung aber
eigentlich gar nicht wahr dass mir sogar
so fertig stiefel angeregt werden wollen
okay die beauty akademie hier bei der
bonität aber auch ordentlich werbung
grill oder soll ich mich hier von beauty
kurs anmelden ihr köln zur anmeldung
das ist ja juti kurs lage design
ausbildung grundkurs in köln 675 euro
zur anmeldung alexandra wie also
schreibt das jetzt einfach mal dazu was
bei rumkommen würde wenn man youtube
werbung einkauft nageldesign ausbildung
675 euro
und ich würde sagen eine sache geht noch
ich frag mich wo ich gerade gelandet bin
glücksrad kuchen challenge weitere ab
jetzt dauerhaft erhältlich bei rossmann
super das funktioniert ja echt
einwandfrei weil der bei elektronischer
stich heiler ach so leute ich sitze
gerade im schnitt und habe ganz
vergessen zu sagen bei welchen preis
nicht und am ende war also wenn man
wirklich alles kaufen würde werden bei
2.300 euro gruppe also mir ganz schöne
menge
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das alles
produkte sind die man unbedingt als jura
aktiver youtube zuschauer kauft aber gut
also 2300 euro achso so insekten
behandlung hier muss ich sagen dass ich
studiere ja selber medien und
kommunikationsmanagement da geht es auch
viel um marketing und das hat man
wirklich sehr gut umgesetzt wir haben
draußen sehr viele mücken die kommen
nachts gerne in die zimmer rein und dann
wäre tot gestochen und dann jetzt hier
auf youtube sollen bei der
elektronischen stich haider zu
platzieren das ist natürlich ein richtig
geschickter marketing ruf ich würde
sagen david beende ich das video und mit
sehr gespannt hier vor allem auf den
swimmingpool dazu wird auf jeden fall
ein video kommt bei einer bock drauf
habt also schreibt es in die kommentare
gebt noch nach oben wenn ihr die idee
cool findet und man kann das natürlich
auch noch mit jeglicher anderen werbung
machen deswegen hast mich das gerne
wissen und ja wir sehen uns morgen wir
haut rein
achso für das morgige video könnt ihr
mir gerne auf instagram ein foto von
euch schicken wenn man euch ganz sieht
und mir eure größe dazu schreiben dann
kommt ihr vielleicht ins video chat oder
instagram ab ganz wichtig alex ihre sich
auf instagram das war habe ich glaube
schon sagt zschau